Elizabeth Warren and damage control
after failing to give Kamala Harris her
full endorsement to be on Biden's 2024
ticket
he should run again and he is running
again because he has gotten a tremendous
amount done Kamala Harris be that his
choices second time around you know I I
really want to defer to what makes Biden
comfortable on his team but they need
they have to be a team in my sense is
they are I don't mean that by suggesting
I think there are any problems I think
they are
that is obviously raising eyebrows and
forcing Warren to later clarify saying
quote she fully supports the presidents
and vice president's reelection together
and never intended to imply otherwise
but you gotta wonder why would Liz say
something like that in the first place
and while Biden is still weeks away from
making his 2024 campaign official
Democrats in New Hampshire are not being
quiet about how much they don't want
Biden to run only 18 percent of Voters
are backing the big guy they prefer
Buddha judge instead
well I guess first of all let me let me
stick with Elizabeth Warren uh I'll
start with you Dana I mean she's not a
fan of Kamala Harris and you can't help
but agree with her initial take that she
had to clarify because everybody's just
waiting for kamala's next word salad or
next foot in the mouth their next mess
yeah so
Elizabeth Warren should probably know
that the only answer to that question is
yes
otherwise you're going to get a lot of
raised eyebrows as we said she um also
made a mistake but sometimes when you're
doing a radio interview you think you're
just talking to your friend right you
host a radio interview you know that you
can get people to say just about
anything because you think nobody's
actually watching then can you imagine
having to be at the White House and you
you're on the Kamala police beat and
you're always looking to see and you
know that Republicans are going to
criticize her but then you're like wait
it keeps coming the calls are coming
from inside the house the problems are
with even within the Democratic party I
had the brain room look up how many
times in history a president has
switched horses for a re-election it's
very few times and I don't think that's
going to happen this time the other
thing about Elizabeth Warren is she's
getting ready I believe for a
re-election run of her own she's up in
2024 but I would not at all be surprised
if she would take or even ask for a
cabinet position with the Biden
Administration so that she could leave
the Senate interesting uh you don't see
her running for president for President
no okay all right so Biden claims Jesse
that he's optimistic about America's
economy and America's future but the
latest NBC poll says otherwise 77 71
percent of Americans think the country's
headed in the wrong direction is Joe not
getting it well he's optimistic because
he's going to cut Kamala from the ticket
now my sources inside the vice
president's office are saying that combo
is actually calling Warren Pocahontas
now behind her back I have about three
or four sources telling me that so you
could take that to the bank
Warren
no one was talking about this she just
introduces this idea no one had brought
this up yep she's the only one bringing
it up all you have to say is they made a
great team they won they'll do it again
it does seem though that she doesn't
like Kamala because she feels Kamala by
way of luck leapfrogged her into the
rightful
line of secession and secession saying
she flamed out before she even took off
Kamal Harris
Warren got delegates Warren was polling
pretty well she stayed in that primary
for a while she did and now commas I
guess The Heir Apparent it should have
been Warren that was The Heir Apparent
so she's trying to plan a little colonel
and Joe Biden said you know Joe if
you're thinking about something you want
a dropper I'm over here in Massachusetts
yeah put it out there yeah that sounds
pretty reasonable to me Harold and and
yet the Buddha excuse that mayor from
Indianapolis you know the guy who was
all over the uh
the South Bend mayor look one of the
reasons I think you could probably pull
a lot of people and they would pull a
higher in New Hampshire than President
Biden many of the Democrats they're
upset that he's decided to move New
Hampshire out of the order being the
number two uh the first uh the first
primary I think in the in the
presidential race look I I give Senator
Warren misspoke I think Dana's right you
sometimes when you're on radio you don't
get a sense of how you look and how you
sound she came right back and corrected
it did she think she should have been
the VP I don't know
um but the reality is she came back and
wholeheartedly in full and gave a full
thrown endorsement of the of the two uh
I've said all along and I think one of
the things that the vice president can
do to strengthen herself and the
president and more importantly the
country would be to focus on crime and
immigration can you imagine who I think
she has the credentials to be a crime
fighter she was a great crime fighter in
California she's had some missteps and
we've certainly talked about it on this
show but can you imagine her convening
police Chiefs around the country to talk
about if we should have standards in
training what they should look like what
we should be doing differently in terms
if in indeed we know we think
anecdotally and I think we're probably
right that this cash or spell stuff is
not working what is the best thing that
could be done
she won't do it those are the kinds of
things that I would advise her team to
be doing to to not only help herself but
it would strengthen the body politic and
more importantly the nation why doesn't
she do it I don't know I you know I'm
with I'm with Jesse on this
Liz isn't supporting Kamala because she
feels Kamala cut in line right Kamala
was the least popular least persuasive
candidate and she hopped to the front of
the line and why because she ticked the
right boxes and Liz is pissed off and I
agree with her imagine trying to cut in
line based on your identity or Heritage
yeah imagine if you even embellished or
lied to get into an Ivy League college
right so she has every right and I think
she's definitely sending smoke signals
out there that that we should all have
reservations
oh don't bury the hatchet Liz
you're done well yes very good I want to
Brian kill Mead I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now